although there's no hard evidence to
support Warren's claim of Native
American ancestry she has cited family
lore and not just a stray remarks about
her cheekbones like that could be in the
onion that literally could be in the
onion all right this is a special
episode here if I have to be mover here
because you can tell the microphone
assist is it a different don't don't
don't cut to it yet there I get it's in
a different position because we have a
live guest in studio a good friend of
mine actually you know I'm on YouTube
how the world works he wrote the book
was it enroll responsibly please and
earlier please enroll response them
because he's a polite little Jewish boy
and also U of M legal scholar Lee Doran
thank you sir for being back in the
program thank you for having me well you
haven't been doing the political thing a
lot lately I have not I used to be very
involved and doing those critique
fact-checking videos and kind of took a
little break this is true and it's and
he emailed me out of the blue just with
I think it might have was at 50
Washington Post fact checks from you and
you were like we might have to whittle
this down but he what was the what
spawned you just decide I read I read
The Washington Post fact-checking on a
Donald Trump speech that he gave in
Montana yeah and they said 76% of his
claims are false so I'm like well that's
a lot let me actually look at what they
did and they reviewed 97 of his claims
and they were wrong on a significant
number of their pet chicken right yeah
but okay but see now I'm not hearing the
passion I did in the phone call when you
called me you were pretty pissed it was
one of the worst fact-checking I've ever
seen and this is one thing I think
what's really important so we're going
to go through 12 today 12 of I I guess
probably the most egregious examples of
the fact check and yes sometimes it's
not just so much factoring you'll see
it's just sort of they decide to
fact-check frivolities which really
don't matter and that again lends itself
to the narrative i think what's
important is Facebook Twitter YouTube
along with the Southern Poverty Law
Center they hold these people out of the
arbiters of truth snopes politifact
washington post right it's no PolitiFact
has a meter washington who is yeah
Tokyo's the Washington Post has the
Pinocchio Pinocchio okay that's right so
um that's what's important is people
rely on them for truth and like you you
were saying just before we started
recording it it's not so much that they
they told half-truths or outright lied
it
that they felt so comfortable yeah and
they've essentially anointed themselves
you know the arbiters of truth and I
think a lot of times that you know you
may differ a little bit on this but I
think a lot of times they're
fact-checking things that they don't do
all the work on or they're not
completely competent to talk about and
then they just make a declaration that
oh four Pinocchios or pants on fire and
they know that people are not going to
actually take the time to read their
analysis yeah and those type of
headlines is what makes the news I don't
think you're wrong but you know it's a
50/50 shot if you hire someone
incompetent why wouldn't any why
wouldn't these people be incompetent and
give us one every now and then why are
they incompetent and it always stacks up
against Donald Trump or conservatives
and that's best that's true I think Adam
Carolla has made this point before that
you know if you expected someone to deal
with change you know back and forth
you'd expect to win about 50% of the
time like they were always messing up
but it seems to always be in their favor
and so that does eventually is as you'll
go through these these fact checks it's
it's pretty bad this one okay all right
so let's go through a few of these we'll
just start with your one that you sent
that I thought was pretty funny so to
keep to make this clear these were fact
checks from Washington Post regarding
statements Donald Trump made and then we
are fact-checking there fact checks
exactly it's like the inception of
fact-checking yeah
so first we'll give you the quote that
Donald Trump gave and then the claim so
the quote from Donald Trump on this one
was yes jawed test you voted for liberal
Obama judges who tried to take away your
second embed bend Washington Post
claimed this misleading right they said
it's not clear which judges Trump was
referring to but tester has an a-minus
rating from the National Rifle
Association his website states as a gun
owner john has voted against legislation
that would violate Montana and Second
Amendment rights and here he goes so
this is something they claim that it is
misleading but it's wrong what's the
truth here what Trump said is 100% true
okay Jon Tester appointed justice
Sotomayor right period it doesn't matter
what his opinion is what Jon Tester
was voted on by the NRA the question is
his judgment for justice Sotomayor right
and justice Sotomayor basically does not
believe that you have an individual
right to own a gun on a handgun and we
know this because in the Chicago versus
McDonald case all right down over the
Chicago case right where Chicago banned
a man from buying a handgun it was
illegal and
she said that this the states have a
right to basically ban a person from
owning a handgun now the Washington Post
what they actually go into this they say
well she was also in the dissent in a
later case in 2016
known as Voisine mm-hmm was een did not
go into the constitutional issues of the
Second Amendment no and they said she
was on the Descent with Justice Thomas I
actually read the case she said
specifically she did not agree with
Justice Thomas on we've covered a lot
too obviously Heller versus DC yeah talk
about the dissenting opinions we said
listen legally the dissenting opinion
here is there is no private right to
firearm ownership at all it's not okay
maybe not assault weapons it's not a ban
on magazines if you look at hella versus
DC you look at the dissent it really
draws a clear line legally that's what
the dissenting judges were saying there
and it's similar obviously a different
case but it's it's the same opinion so
they're fact-checking him for basically
not liking someone are using words they
don't like but like you said the nra
writing could not be less relevant if
you don't believe in the private right
to firearm on and they tried to obscure
the facts here because in 2008 is when
the Heller decision was in 2009 is when
Sotomayor was brought in the courts
let's say oh we don't know what she
thinks on this right well the Chicago
decision came out the year afterwards
and she literally brought Justice Breyer
gave the dissent and he referred back to
the Heller case she said [ __ ] was wrong
yeah we don't have an individual right
to own a handgun and she sided with him
on that case yeah so unless the
Washington Post wants to argue with a
straight face that banning someone from
owning a handgun is not taking away your
Second Amendment rights
I don't know what the heck they're
talking about I don't know either it
sounds like wordplay to me alright well
go on to number two
this is from the donald donald trump
quote we've said the suburbs and even
though we got a little surprised vote
that evening you all remember that
evening somebody came in with a thumbs
down after camp a date for years that he
was going to repeal and replace and he
was talking of course about john mccain
and washington post their claim was that
this statement is mostly false what they
wrote as Trump is referring to Senator
John McCain but complained McCain
complained about the bill had not gone
through right give us the truth on this
they bait he's talking about John McCain
and they say he's wrong his exact quote
about John McCain John McCain ran
against Ann Kirkpatrick
okay he has if you go to his YouTube
channel you can see tons of his attack
videos against Obama care about his need
to repeal Obamacare against Anne
Kirkpatrick that she's going to support
Obama
he ran on repealing Obamacare then at
the eleventh hour he comes in and goes I
have some procedural problems on
repealing Obamacare and at the last
minute when everyone assumed he was
gonna you know support right repealing
it comes in does the thumb down everyone
goes over shocked yeah and Washington
Post says Trump is wrong here I don't
know what where they're getting this
from well you know it's funny that if
John McCain had ever won the election
they'd be doing the exact same thing
with McCain it doesn't matter how
moderate you are no it's like well I'm
like hey why couldn't we have a McCain
the Republican Party now it's become
crazy they did the same thing with John
McCain yeah it was a war Hawk he was out
of his mind he was crazy he was losing
as much the actuary tables of something
that Matt Damon brought up he was likely
to die then all of a sudden they're
supporting Bernie Sanders so it is
important to note I think to the
historical context where now they come
to the aid of John McCain to try and
attack Donald they would do the exact
same thing back then well if you
remember prior when he ran against bush
and and it was he was always the
favorite of the media until he was a
threat to actually taking away their
power from our Democrats and now all the
sudden he's this evil person who's gonna
you know do all these bad things in a
war Hawk and so on but when he's in the
opposition to his own party
then we need to you know say how let me
ask you this if someone who's a lawyer
he's a lawyer when they say that this is
false Donald for president Trump speaks
out of turn we both know that sometimes
he says things that you know it off use
case the truth or just make stuff up
okay if we can give you that fine but in
this case it is accurate to the letter
as to what john mccain did why do you
think they say it's misleading is that
incompetence i think i think in part
it's incompetence you're right about the
issue of it does seem a little suspect
if they're always wrong in one direction
but you know it's so specific and he's
right i I honest I almost there's almost
no response to it they're on the DL
seriousness in this particular case we
see video of John McCain putting out
attack ads and saying why he's going to
run on doing this Trump says he ran on
this and gave us a late surprise vote
and it seems like they're only focused
on that 11th hour discussion of McCain
being like I got some procedural
problems with how this is going about
your candidacy give it a thumbs down
yeah exactly and so the the fact that he
gave a late justification when he does
any more time on this Lee see this thing
he's a lawyer he'll talk about this to
the cows come home lie
that ones we can we can shock up to the
like category come on you're trying to
be sometimes like it's in comedy he said
he was right on this campaign on this
than the last minute thumbs down and I
don't know how they say miss some of
these we can go oh why are you factoring
this it's so absurd and we'll get to a
few of those yeah but there are a few
clear-cut examples where he is so on the
right and that's where that's where it
forces people like me who were not
President Donald Trump fans and I don't
think you were necessarily in the
primary to come to his defense because
of the constant attacks when there's so
unwarned what what drives me crazy is he
does kind of extend what the truth is
all the time
and I think it's partly because he's
kind of a you know binary person it's
either good or bad and so rather than
getting a specific number right he'll if
it's going up he'll say it's the
greatest thing ever if it's going down
it's the worst thing ever right and so
when he's off by quite a bit because
isn't really care about the individual
numbers felt fat check everything he
says well he's in the same with John
McCain like John McCain's great oh my
god jabba Kate sucks you know he just
goes right back and forth by the two by
the way you appreciate it I am the
Walter away from you yeah thank you it's
not loaded for people who who know thank
you fantastic sponsor we appreciate you
author okay since the election we've
created in wealth seven trillion dollars
in Washington Post claim this is
misleading this appears to be based on
the performance of the Russell 3000
index since Trump's inauguration this
index includes nearly 98 percent of US
stocks but the market capitalization of
the top US companies is not a good
indicator of wealth gains for the
general type that's out you hear hopper
he's mad that you're not petting him
right now Justin just in case you were
wondering this is this is an on-air
unedited just two guys in a studio so
what what's the truth about Donald
Trump's statement there about wealth
creation if you listen to their analysis
they basically admit what he said is
true we created that we created that
amount of wealth and you might say I
mean even when Trump ran I think in you
know against Hillary said that the stock
market was a bubble or whatever he said
doesn't matter if you're saying the
wealth is created which it was he might
be off by point one I think if they want
to get him on the point one they can get
him on the point one but it was created
and period the statement from the from
the start of that sentence to the end of
the sentence is accurate right well
what's funny is is they try to argue
that's nuanced or even when you came to
me and you said okay I want to provide
context of these answers I was gonna law
second before we get into context let's
just go boom the truth because people
need to hear if it's true or not and
then you provide the context and I think
that's a big difference between the left
and the right the
always wants to deal in context and then
not really provide a definitive
statement whereas you do provide a
definitive statement sometimes of the
lawyer you provide the context first I
believe in providing a definitive
statement first and then the context
good example here might be okay let's
say I say I give you ten dollars and I
say I gave him ten dollars and you say
well yeah but I was taxed and I only had
six dollars left wopo can come out and
say well he didn't get sick he didn't
get ten dollars that's what they're
doing here I gave you ten dollars
but you didn't get ten dollars at the
end of the day and so they claim that
he's a liar yeah well they're claiming
that this the stock market isn't a good
indicator of the country's wealth but
he's pointing out that we created X
amount of wealth which we did right
since he's been in office now you can
argue whether the result of him or not
and this is the thing that bothers me
the most they have ways that they could
actually provide analysis back and forth
about a legitimate debate on policy and
they don't do that they come out and say
pants on fire and then they give garbage
analysis well they use those indicators
under Obama - it's well yeah if that
happened under Obama that's why they
didn't include the job participation
right so they use different indicators
when it's convenient the truth is the
number that he what we're not trying to
get into his not not make an argument at
all his policies are right not making an
argument that even the way he's framed
these things are necessarily correct but
that his statement in and of itself
which is what they're analyzing was
truthful yes okay here's another one
that they thought was really necessary
effect so he said and I didn't pay 1.8
billion by the way in cash we paid
nothing Washington Post claimed that
this was misleading this was Trump
comparing his dealings with North Korea
to Obama's dealings with Iran this is
from Washington Post the money in
question which is actually 1.7 billion
was iran's all along and was sent by the
Obama administration has settled
decades-old claim and he when they go on
they provide a little bit more context
but as to the claim itself where he said
I didn't pay 1.8 billion by the way in
cash we paid nothing that's true I mean
that's what drives me crazy from start
to finish the claim is true he did not
pay money for the hostages now the
context behind that and and there's
there so this is what drives me nuts
there's some truth to the way Washington
Post could have responded to this but it
shouldn't be part of this fact check
because from start to finish it's true
we basically had a there the Iran's
money frozen from a arms-dealing we had
before they took our hostages in the 70s
right and we kept that money didn't
arms you said you took our hostages
we're keeping the money and it's been
going through litigation for decades
right and now Obama administration says
ok we're gonna settle this because we
might lose in this international
tribunal and so now we're gonna give you
the money you make it ran sound like
it's mattress girl but yes very much and
they said ok we're gonna give you this
money and on a settlement and and then
they dropped four hundred billion
dollars and million dollars in cash yeah
airdrop too because for the left who do
they deal so much in nuance right they
don't explain any of the nuance they
just say it was rands all along to begin
with like well hold on a second why was
that in dispute could it be hostages
could there be a long-standing crisis
and negotiate they just say it was rands
all along and then go on to talk about
how the nuance of president Ahnold
Trump's statement is wrong this this
statement itself doesn't you could fact
check their fact-checking of the
fact-checking and get into the nuance
and talk about why they're wrong and why
it wasn't arranged all along it they
could actually do a good service and
actually provide some context and
analysis of that where that 1.8 trillion
dollars
I mean billion dollars comes from yeah
um it's hard to yeah exactly
exactly but they don't and what was what
was crazy is and what Trump was
referring to as we air dropped 400
million of that literally into Iran the
same day the hostage came out and they
go it's a coincidence it has nothing to
do right there's nothing to do with the
fact of the deal in fact we agreed to
give them the 1.8 a while back and so
yeah I don't people start watching paint
dry and Lou of this but that is an
important clip okay here's another one
where he says referring to of course
Hillary Clinton we need to provide the
context everybody but this is part of
the big umbrella was at 76% at which had
the number of yeah of Donald Trump
statements are untrue so let us know
what you think what percentage of
statements from Donald Trump are are
true or untrue what percentage of those
would you file under pivotal issues
would you file under non negotiables
closed handed issues versus I don't know
he gets pissed off because the Cowboys
lost the Super Bowl or something okay
comment below so this claim time a
Hillary Clinton she gets special
treatment under the Justice Department
and by the way I also want to clued same
claim because otherwise we'll be here
all day
he also said how about that FBI agent
how about that guy you think there was
just a little bias there a little bias
oh do we catch them in the act
it's rigged it's a rigged deal folks oh
he's talking about obviously there so
let start with Hillary Clinton these are
both kind of the same claim where he's
talking about special treatment
Washington Post claims that both of them
not misleading false let's star with
Hillary Clinton the statement she was
given special treatment and there's
there's proof to this and what bothers
me is when people lie to themselves I
dare anybody to do exactly what Hillary
Clinton did and try to stay out of jail
literally take a server put it in your
bathroom put classified information on
there send it all around and expect that
you're not going to go to jail for
exactly what she did and then when they
ask to subpoena stuff tear it all up and
bleach pit it and get get rid of all
that of course you got special treatment
yeah now what what's ironic about this
the special treatment that they got is
if you remember they found anthony
Weiner's when they were doing an
investigation they found some of
Hillary's you know emails from his wife
well they found out they had based on
the bias that they had against Trump
they sat on Anthony Weiner's of material
and didn't investigate it yeah and then
at the last minute it became an October
Surprise because the New York FBI said
hey guys are you gonna go check on this
stuff yeah and Comey comes into last
minute October goes oh there's some
stuff we got to check out and ironically
the bias worked against them I want to
go back to that point really quickly
about about weiner cuz also in that same
thing was we were talking about about
Peter stroke yeah how it's spelled STR Z
okay for people who don't know I just
never want to pronounce it incorrectly
so I deliberately pronounce it
incorrectly did he get a special
treatment as well did he get special
treatment yeah certainly seems like it I
mean I mean I don't know how you can be
on the case and basically saying we're
gonna stop Donald Trump which he said
and he texted to his girlfriend that
where I stopped them and you get to stay
on the case and example to in these
these media outlets give special
treatment so you mentioned Anthony
Weiner and you you and I both knew
Andrew Breitbart while he was alive yeah
and I I was a little bit closer with him
I checked with a moored at Breitbart but
I remember he really enjoyed your videos
and and we all sat down a couple of
times and the Anthony Weiner scans a lot
of people don't remember this before
Andrew Breitbart took over Anthony
Weiner's press conference remember they
said that Andrew Breitbart was lying yes
they said Andrew Burke came on said
there are pictures from Anthony Weiner
that he's been exchanging with young
women on Twitter and out of respect for
his family I don't wanna release these
picture
but this is obviously this is obviously
very incriminating and obviously his
concern was the leverage against a
sitting senator yeah and they said this
is a lot as Breitbart lies and they
didn't cover it and as a matter of fact
Anthony Weiner was going to deliver that
press conference to completely deny the
allegations until Andrew Breitbart took
that stage never clear as day
you heard screaming for the building
Andrew Breitbart sinned the building he
went up took over the press conference
and Anthony Weiner had to abandon his
talking points so the media was doing
Anthony Weiner's bidding back then only
when it became so overwhelming meaning
the actual space odyssey' upward angle
picture of his penis did they finally
admit it well and you basically shamed
them into actually covering it is what
he did right I mean at some point the
evidence was so overwhelming that it
wasn't some hacking or anything like
that it was what Anthony Weiner did and
people they didn't want to believe it
and they want to do everything they
could to cover you know to cover for
they called him a liar yes and they
didn't do any due diligence there and
even they'd even try to look into it
because we've had this happen to with
we've dealt with um like the Austin
Chronicle we've had to deal with a lot
of papers or when we dealt with Utah an
toughie
these local papers we go here's someone
handing Jared a shiv here's them talking
about luring Trump supporters ben
shapiro uh you know attendees to their
cars with sawed-off shotguns here they
are doing it on camera and every one
every single person in local media
turned away the only well who didn't
were the police who took us into the cop
car to get the footage and then the FBI
who made the calls afterward so there
really is that I think they're real
overarching truth here that people need
to understand is you can't just you
can't just appeal to Authority and
whether it's the scientific community
whether it's journalistic integrity
whether it's identity politics it
doesn't mean that anyone's opinion is
invalid I'm not saying don't trust them
what I'm saying is you can't simply
throw your hands up and say well I trust
Washington Post right trust Snopes or I
trust the person who wrote this one
scientific study you do have to
aggregate it and make your own
inferences exactly and and it goes back
to the point that we were talking about
is that you know the people are not they
assume that the people aren't actually
they're not gonna go check the facts on
their own they're not gonna go look up
the PDF oh yeah Paris climate Accords
and go read and go that's written right
there
that's what's so disturbing to me that's
what's so disturbing to me is a complete
total lack of accountability
it's it's not that put it this way a
bully in school has to punch you in the
bathroom right he has to try and look he
has to look around a little bit make
sure but if if it would be way more
disturbing if bullies in school we're
just kicking the crap and curb stomping
kids right there in front of the Dean
they're going okay
all right good have a good day that's
what's so disturbing these people are
doing it in plain sight because they
don't believe that anyone has any
intention of fact-checking them and sure
let anyone else in the media or the
teachers you know trippin the kids down
the hallway yes yes that could happen
too that happened to me actually several
times in the principal looked away yeah
when I saw the principal look away Athan
well okay maybe I deserve that one all
right
I'm not speaking of low IQ individuals
missus we'll hit the sensor button
because that's her actual name uh he
said this is Maxine Waters she is a low
IQ individual okay vaccine waters she
said what in the mid 60s
I believe that Washington Post claimed
and of course toss this under the 76
percent umbrella that this is false
what's the truth I don't even know how
they're fact-checking this I mean does
the average citizen does the average
citizen when they're sitting at home and
they're thinking Washington Post comes
out with a fact check comes out with a
headline do they think they're really
gonna check fact-checking insult yeah
you know wasn't an insult though or do
you think like do you think that he
doesn't understand that 60s is actually
functionally [ __ ] I I think I think
Trump is very aware of what he does it
if you think you know is that 60s is
like functionally [ __ ] yes I think
he's very he's very well aware and and
and so what bothers me is he's throwing
an insult but she's you think he knows
it like sixties IQ with water burn baby
freaked out I think so I think I think
so I and then here it's it's just it's
frustrating to see this type of thing
thrown into that again it literally is
in the mix with trade policy with NATO
with Supreme Court decisions with the
Second Amendment and Oh Roger Goodell
gets paid this amount and Maxine Waters
has low IQ it's like I know well listen
this is Russian prostitutes peeing on
furniture with the vinyl still on
Elizabeth Ward proclaims that she's of
Indian heritage because her mother says
she has in fact the fact that I'm
reading this quote and I know that
there's a fact check Washington Post
it's what's so hard to deal with like
it's like what I do box
and you're hitting the mid sandboxing
the guy says to throw it throw it - but
he already knows it and he swings at you
before because he knows what you're
gonna throw it's like I'm reading this
out I know what they're gonna do I know
what he says and I know they're gonna
fat chicken anyway I don't know Kay
because her mother says she has high
cheekbones that's her only evidence that
her mother said she has high cheekbones
Washington Post claims is false and they
actually write this although there's no
hard evidence to support Warren's claim
of Native American ancestry she has
cited family lore and not just a stray
remarks about her cheekbones like that
could be in the am that literally could
be in the onion I mean the fact that the
the the angle that they chose for it was
not whether or not she was being
untruthful about her heritage it was she
also cited not just her cheekbones but
family lore - yeah and so he we he
should have also said family lore and
then would the claim be true I don't
know but if it also if they cared about
truth wouldn't they just do the 23andme
what's the genetic heritage testing I
don't know it'd be really easy to do
I've done it I hate that I did it
because I'm mostly French did the thing
is there's there's no evidence that she
was I made a minority and back when they
didn't have you know the internet what
they had was the equivalent of LinkedIn
and use directories yeah and what she
did was is she listed herself as a
minority in the directory and it was the
type of thing that she clearly knew I
mean you can't prove she knew but she
knew that you know if you were listed as
a minority you would get some
preferential treatment for hiring and
she was listed as the derp in the
directory as a minority and it Uncle
Sam's none the wiser
if you like this video you first off
should probably seek counseling but you
should subscribe or hit the notification
bell or watch one of these videos that's
playing truth is I don't know what any
of that means anymore if you try and
subscribe it the notification bell you
won't be notified and if you try click
one of these videos it's just going to
take you to BuzzFeed boldly fat frauds
as they get carried out of their houses
we're late to break down the north wall
and they get carried out in a land well
tarp I don't know what's happening on
YouTube I know what's happening with mug
Club ladders credit calm slash month let
me get to watch The Daily Show one hour
every single day not just clips along
with like 15 other shows for 69 dollars
annually if your student and/or veteran
or military and you get to keep us here
on you
two for free because we can we can
irritate them by your support it's worth
it right